diversity really is the religion of the
University I hope that we can start
asking them to better preach what they
practice we've all seen the trend on
college campuses with students demanding
safe spaces to protect themselves from
the opinions they don't like but how
much of that PC hysteria is being driven
from within the ivory tower for
progressives will the school you need to
get out to find out we talked to John
shields professor at Claremont McKenna
College and co-author of passing on the
right conservative professors in the
progressive university it's the first
book length study on conservatives in
academia why do this and how did you
send us out these mythical creatures
hardly I was interested because I'm a
conservative professor so it was a topic
that I was interested in also I think
conservative professors provide an
interesting window into the university
but also an interesting window into
conservatives in itself and they were
hard to find in some ways you know I
mean they're rare right so in the social
sciences where I work they're so rare
that they're outnumbered by Marxist say
like a five to one ratio yeah right
that's right so so about five percent of
social scientists self-identify as
Republicans and and we knew that some of
them would be closeted so that presented
other challenges shields uncovered these
closeted conservatives by first
approaching professors proudly out of
the closet and writing for conservative
publications he then got them to name
names until he had a healthy sample size
when you say conservatives libertarians
are included in this mix as well that's
right we think of conservativism or
American the American right as a
coalition against liberalism my
colleague James Caesar put it really
well he said you know American
conservatives they're united by two
self-evident truths Barbara Boxer and
Nancy Pelosi that is to say they share a
common enemy but not necessarily common
philosophical views or a common policy
agenda always and and and it's a
coalition that's included libertarian
even though there are sometimes a
disgruntled sort of faction of the other
republican party in the american right
yeah what i found interesting is that
libertarians actually feel a lot more
comfortable i guess they don't feel they
need to really closeted themselves they
do you know it's much better to be pro
market then you know pro-family or to be
a social conservative and it's also the
case that libertarians tend to gravitate
toward economics and economics is just
kind of weird you know it's a much more
tolerant place than the rest of the
social sciences I mean you know when we
talk to economists they said you know if
you were if you were a free-market type
in the post-war era now that was a very
difficult place to be right if you
weren't at Keynes Ian you were sort of
out of the out of the club but the
Chicago School really changed that a lot
right you had a lot of Nobel Prize
winners and economics in the 1950s
people like Milton Friedman and Hayek so
even as the university has really
drifted leftward it's a place that's
become somewhat more friendly to people
with market friendly views but we see a
lot in the news a lot of Republican
presidential candidates that have
decried the state of the University and
have branded it as as a liberal
indoctrination chamber it's not a
legitimate criticism and what did the
professor say that you talked to you I
mean do they think that they're being
treated fairly
it's just grossly overstated you know
and I get why conservatives outside the
institution distrust it right and why
they they react in the way that they do
sometimes but now I think the university
is a much more tolerant place than
movement conservatives and certainly
Republican candidates often think that
it is and and certainly Republic you
know conservatives inside the university
often told us they said you know it's
not that bad right it's not nearly as
bad as David Horowitz says it is or
Marco Rubio recently on the campaign
trail I think you're right he did call
it an indoctrination camp yeah it's a
much more tolerant place and I think
that's partly because there
partly because there's tenure
right I mean 10 years a very important
institution even though some
conservatives tend to closeted
themselves as junior professors they
almost always come out of the closet
after 10 year and then they get to do
what they want to do right so the
tolerance of the Academy doesn't rest
entirely on the social psychology of
liberal professors right it's really
protected by this powerful institution
maybe a lot of people on the right
sometimes view 10 here a little bit
suspiciously but that could be a good
benefit of absolutely I mean it made I
mean writing this book and doing the
research for made us much more
sympathetic to 10-year right because we
we saw what a difference it made in the
lives of these conservatives and so I
think conservatives should be out in
front defending tenure actually and that
doesn't I mean of course it has problems
right that's absolutely true
but given the fact that you know it does
protect political minorities and allows
them to express their views freely
that's that's important it's something
we should defend as conservatives and
libertarians there's this prevailing
idea that I guess stems from a study
done way back when that conservatives
and libertarians they're not in the
university because they just don't have
the mind to be academics which just
seems like such an outdated idea why do
you think this still persists I think it
partly persist because there are so few
conservatives about in academia so when
my liberal colleagues or when many of
them think about conservatives they
think about its most populist
expressions right they think about Sarah
Palin Donald Trump Michelle Bachman and
that's because they don't really
encounter many right-wing intellectuals
the liberal or once liberal social
psychologist Jonathan hight I wrote a
book called the righteous mind and he's
got this wonderful description of
browsing in a used bookstore he picked
up a volume on conservative thought that
was written by Jerry Muller and he said
he had to sit down a few pages into it
right he was quite literally floored
because he had never encountered
anything like this before
you know heights a bright guy he's
well-read but yet he had never
encountered conservative ideas at that
level before right and and it's hard to
imagine a conservative professor having
a similar experience right picking up a
book on Marxism and being floored right
picking up a book on post-modernism and
having their hair blown back right it
just that doesn't happen because they're
swimming in those kinds of intellectual
currents it's all around them but if
you're even if you're somebody like
Jonathan Hyde even if you're someone
that well-read and broad-minded you can
miss right conservative ideas there's
got to be some real-world consequences
to not having a diversity of opinion on
a faculty staff you know when
disciplines become so homogeneous that
such that there's no center-right people
about or hardly any it's really hard for
those disciplines to converge on the
best approximation in the truth right
they might produce good work but but
they they struggle to seek truth and
they and that's partly because of the
enduring influence of confirmation bias
right that is we all have a tendency to
accept findings and theories that fit
our pre-existing point points of view
and so to really be challenged to really
have to confront our position in a
serious way we need to encounter people
who disagree with us and then I think
it's also the case that a lot of
students don't really get exposed to
center-right ideas right and even if you
were a liberal professor who really
wanted to expose your students to a
broad range of views right whole bodies
of knowledge are so distorted it seems
to me by leftist paradigms and
assumptions that you really have to look
long and hard for some more dissonant
center-right voices even if the teachers
or professors want to include more it
seems that students now are very
sensitive
two different opinions we've seen
speakers disinvited we've seen you know
the whole safe space controversy kind of
explode do you think that's a bit of a
reflection of the fact that it is so
one-sided and that for so long now that
other viewpoints have been in the
minority good education should be
offensive right and it should be
offensive because it can it really does
pit competing conceptions of the good or
competing conceptions of justice against
one another right so being offended it
seems to me is the price that we pay for
our diversity it's the price we pay for
a good education and if you want a
different kind of education right if you
want an inoffensive education it seems
to me you go you go to a fundamentalist
college or something like that so that's
the model it seems to me of an age of an
education that's intentionally non
offensive right it's trying to shelter
those students it's trying to protect
them from views right that that might
undermine their faith communities and I
don't need to denigrate that kind of
education I think there's an important
place for it in American education but
it's not the model it seems to me of a
secular liberal arts education